este vtr 80 de
1986 llega a la línea de frente
pues sí
los soldados vigilan las trincheras
temiendo la cercanía de exploradores
rusos solo
ambas
tablets y chang tang es doble mal su
nombre de guerra es caporal él y sus
equipos mantiene la defensa desde estas
trincheras en el corazón del donbass a
pesar del desequilibrio entre las
fuerzas que se enfrentan
balotelli
según él las tropas rusas tendrían entre
20 y 30 veces más armamento que ellos el
fósforo está prohibido las bombas de
racimo están prohibidas las minas
antipersonas también pero ellos utilizan
todo eso en esta guerra lo utilizan
porque dicen que esto no es una guerra
sino una operación especial
como piensan que no están rompiendo las
convenciones internacionales
algunos soldados están agotados pero
tratan de relajarse con lo que tienen al
alcance
risas
talismán está aquí desde hace tres meses
estamos demasiado cansados no podemos
más no tenemos tiempo para descansar
se acuerdan a las trincheras
hemos cavado extranjeras desde el primer
día que llegamos aquí también es
asistente de cocina
y
los arcos
[Música]
los
deportes
a 17
para el menú de esta noche el
tradicional bolso craneano la cena es un
momento de encuentro entre camaradas de
guerra entre ellos hay un soldado que
participó en unos combates intensos en
cyber donges durante 34 días
espero que seamos suficientes aquí pero
no creo que el problema tenga que ver
con la cantidad de hombres solo
esperamos que la artillería sea
suficiente porque ante la artillería no
se puede hacer casi nada y ellos tienen
mucha
con ilusión
después de comer un último momento de
tranquilidad
pero la amenaza de los drones nunca es
tan hijos de sus casas como
nuestras transacciones electrónicas
estos tramos
yo digo
los soldados hacen su ronda de la noche
listos para enfrentarse al enemigo
sabemos perfectamente a qué nos
enfrentamos
a un enemigo que tiene muchísima fuerza
no es la primera vez estamos convencidos
de que tenemos suficientes recursos para
defender esas posiciones lo peor que
podría pasar ya está ocurriendo en su
sitio la propia guerra
poniendo la desnutrición
benach
a lo lejos estalla una bomba de fósforo
cerca de es lo bianco por nuestra
seguridad los soldados nos llevan a
pasar la noche en un rojo
todos
[Música]
amanece sin ningún incidente importante
en la línea de frente pero caporal hace
una advertencia cuando la noche es
tranquila el día es agitado suele ser
así
para este batallón empieza un nuevo día
en la defensa de slogans durán una
golpeada por el ejército ruso